Duane dog Chapman is devastated after
Beth's personal belongings were stolen
during a burglary of he and his late
wife's store et has obtained the photos
showing the damage done to the Colorado
merchandise store after the break-in
police and dog himself are now on the
hunt for the suspect or suspects just
after 7:30 p.m. on July 30th a
representative from a dog core called
Edgewater police and reported there was
missing merchandise and other items of
personal value the incident is currently
being investigated and police are
following up on leads dog took to
Twitter to address the burglary the
Bible says it is an unforgivable sin to
steal from the dead large cash reward
for any information for who is
responsible for this in addition the
Chapman family released a statement to
ET that read in part not only did the
thieves take thousands of dollars of
clothing these criminals took priceless
personal belongings of our beloved Beth
including tributes to her kindly left by
our amazing fans to whoever did this you
better watch out dog is coming for you
according to a source with direct
knowledge of the situation dog is
devastated over the burglary I haven't
gotten past the place where I'm still
putting a pillow where she was and
covering it up like the jailhouse
escaped hmm right I mean it and then I
wake up me like sear and it doesn't
register getting to her I'm still there
Beth Chapman died on June 26th after a
battle with cancer her final days will
be documented in the new season of dogs
most wanted premiering September 4 I
think that everything is a milestone you
know every every milestone that you meet
you're like yes I made it to Mother's
Day I made it to Easter we're just
living every day as much as we can to
the fullest that we can and trying to
hit every milestone that we can you know
we're just gonna have fun and love each
other and laugh all the way and when it
ends it ends what
[Music]